good morning
it's my great pleasure to be
participating in this celebration of the
30th anniversary of the office of
research on women's health
and i'm going to be talking about
nccih's focus on the health of women
we know that complementary and
integrative health approaches are very
uh used very uh extensively by women 30
percent 37 percent of women compared
with 29 of men
use some a form of complementary
health
and so what are these types of
approaches
we describe them as being in sort of
three broad categories of dietary
psychological and physical
therapies and practices that include
things like for example
nutritional supplements probiotics or
meditation mindfulness-based stress
reduction or a physical therapy such as
manual therapies and of course there's
overlap between these categories for
example yoga is a combination of
psychological and physical component
and we know that uh if we ask
why what is the reason why people use
these types of approaches
a lot of people say that they're using
it for general health wellness
well-being
but a certain percentages of the
population use them for specific health
conditions and what are these health
conditions um when we ask specifically
you can see that overwhelmingly
pain is is a
back pain for example neck pain joint
pain and other musculoskeletal pain are
the four
specific health conditions that are most
frequently cited by by individuals for
their use of these complementary
interventions
and we know that women tend to have
disproportionately greater amounts of
both pain and high impact for chronic
pain
so this is important uh for for the
health of women that we understand how
best to uh to
encourage and the rational use of these
therapies that we do proper research to
understand are these therapies
actually useful are they effective are
they safe
and when we look for our portfolio on
research that relates to women's health
you can see that the pain is very well
represented as well as other topics such
as uh general health well-being stress
etc
so uh talking about pain first um we are
very fortunate that we have been able to
um contribute uh to participate in a
very important heal initiative which
stands for health to end addiction long
term
this is a trans nih effort that is you
that is aimed at
addressing both the opioid epidemic and
also the pain epidemic because we know
that there is a lot of uh
a very extensive uh problem with pain in
this country that
unfortunately all too often results in
the
prescription of opioids and so um nccih
has participated in a uh has been
leading actually a
program called prism which is uh
stands for pragmatic and implementation
studies for the management of pain to
reduce opioid prescribing these are
non-pharmacological approaches these are
examples here for example using uh
transcutaneous electrical nerve
stimulation mindfulness stress reduction
acupuncture and
telehealth for example uh in
in rural communities as well as uh
guided relaxation so um these are kind
of examples of studies that we've been
able to uh fund through the heal
initiative
another important area is uh natural
products and a lot of people use natural
products uh many of them of people in in
in the hope of of helping with pain it's
very important that we understand both
uh the potential use of these products
but also their safety and potential
interactions uh with uh medications for
example or other natural products that
people might be might be taking so for
that uh aim we we held a workshop back
in 2019
that was in collaboration uh with an
inds and ncats and uh this was a very uh
very good workshop in that it really led
to a program that is again in
collaboration with uh not only in ids
and ncaas but also nci um to basically
mine both electronic databases and also
uh natural product libraries um that
already exists that have extensive
collections of natural products that can
then be screened for in phenotypic
assays uh in high throughput screening
for effectiveness in uh targets that
could be um for analgesia and so this
has led to a very nice
collaborative program uh to um very
explore uh and discover
new potential analgesics that derive
from natural products
now be cannabinoids is all are also very
uh much at the front of people's minds
because they're used a lot people use
cannabinoids especially products such as
cbd uh that is available
over the counter and uh we wanted to
make sure that we understand uh if
how effective these are and how safe
these are and so in 2019 uh we made 11
awards to explore pain relieving
properties and mechanisms of actions of
of the many different compounds that are
uh in cannabis including uh cannabinoids
minor terpenes
and uh so
this is again just gives you an idea of
the portfolio and and and and our our um
are the breadth of our research in pain
but as i mentioned before
pain is not the only reason right where
people like people use uh complementary
and integrative health approaches
general health and and well-being is
extremely important in some cases really
in some for example for yoga or um
it was overwhelmingly the reason why
people use this uh this inter this this
these practices or meditation for
example it's for promoting uh health and
well-being and so
we need to understand first of all how
do you do research
on well-being um we are very much geared
towards understanding uh disease right
and we have a lot of sophisticated
measurements of symptoms and and and
uh and disease biomarkers for example
what are the biomarkers of of well-being
and health we need to understand that
right so we had a roundtable in 2018 on
emotional well-being um and uh this uh
was uh uh resulted uh again in a a a
collaboration uh in in the
we funded five research networks um that
will be launched in december 2020
looking at uh ontology of emotional
well-being how do you characterize it
how do you measure it mechanisms
biomarkers uh prevention and also
technology and outcomes measure
development so this is again an effort
that is very sort of
cross-disciplinary and that will help in
further the research on this very
important topic
another exciting initiative that we have
again another uh collaboration this time
between nih the kennedy center and the
national endowments for the art arts um
is the sound health initiative um this
is the goal of this initiative which was
spearheaded by dr francis collins
about is to really increase our
understanding of how music affects
health uh with uh emphasis on basic
neuroscience and also potential uh
clinical applications and just like like
as many of these other initiatives we
really started with a workshop uh that
really brought together an amazing uh
collaboration this was uh back in 2017
uh between again the kennedy center the
nea and many
music therapy professional and advocacy
groups um there was a uh
dr collins participated here with renee
fleming who's a well-known uh
soprano who is very active in this area
of promoting the understanding of music
and uh and its use in in
promoting health
and uh this panel uh sound health
research resulted in
a an initiative that we are now uh
we have funded three grants now in this
area evaluating for uh
example evaluating the impact of singing
our interventions on the markers of
cardiovascular health in older patients
uh the effect of music-based
intervention on neurodevelopment and
pain response and pre-term infants and
also using uh self-generated rhythmic
cues to enhance gait in parkinson's
disease so this is just the beginning
we're really excited about
how we may better understand uh how uh
how music and other arts but for example
uh visual arts
can be um
can be used for promoting health
another area that we're very much
interested in is the connections between
the the mind and the body um one of the
areas where we have developed this is in
the concept of inner reception um this
is the a very important
area of science that is really in need
of further development and so we started
it with a a workshop uh in collaboration
when you see all of these institutes uh
this was sponsored by the
uh
neuroscience blueprint initiative and
what it did so what is inter-reception
it's really the processes by which our
body senses interprets integrates and
regulates signals from within itself so
how does your brain for example perceive
when you are hungry or thirsty or tired
um what are the what are the signals
that come from our body that the brain
then has to the nervous system has to
integrate this is this is really a very
fascinating area that has a lot of uh
bearing understanding this has a lot of
bearing in our understanding of for
example meditation or yoga where you
really focus on your breathing how is it
that you sense that and what information
does it give you
and what can you do about it
so um this workshop uh
is uh was was uh uh in 2019 and explored
various aspects of the neural circuitry
underlying these dynamic interception
interactions the interreceptive
processes associated with certain
diseases and disorders modulating these
processes potentially with the different
interventions and therapies and also
developing the methodology and
technology to better uh do this research
and so we have an rfa that is out the
applications are due soon december 18th
and the goal is to enhance our
fundamental understanding of
interreception with a specific focus on
determining the function of these neural
circuits
so i've talked to uh just this is just a
snapshot summary of that i gave you of
some of the you know exciting
initiatives that we've been involved
involved in but i i'm just want to
finish with this slide that shows you
how this fits into the bigger picture
um nccih is we are in the middle of
developing a new strategic plan and what
we're focusing on is whole person health
research how does all this fit well uh
we we know that um whole the whole
person in health we think about this as
a two axis so on the vertical axis axis
here we have the integration of the sort
of biocycle social elements
as well as the environment because the
environment is very important of course
we know our physical environment as well
as our social environment it's very
important in in in determining uh our
health and within the physiological
domains you have all of these different
systems neural respiratory
cardiovascular digestive etc that need
to interact in that the interception
example i gave you is just an example of
that
and then on the horizontal axis you have
what we call the uh bi-directional
health disease continuum know that
people are traveling along this
continuum back and forth it's not just
one way towards disease and death you
can go back towards health and we think
that a lot of these pharmacological and
non-pharmacological interventions can be
very helpful in helping people
to uh to go back in and restore their
health after they've been sick
or if they have a chronic illness to
help them gain
regain
health and improve and this happens on
the different planes on the
physiological plane as well as in the
social and psychological plane and
symptom management of course is part of
this at every step so managing pain
is part of this of this continuum
so i hope that this kind of gives you an
idea of the exciting uh some of the
exciting initiatives that we're
developing and of course all of this is
relevant to the health of women um and
we really look forward to uh
further discussions with uh orweh on on
how we can further collaborate on on
many of these initiatives
thank you